[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم افادت مراسله الجزيره في تعز بان
المقاومه الشعبيه وقواه الجيش الوطني في
اليمن سيطرت على مواقع مهمه في الاطراف
الغربيه والجنوبيه للمدينه بعد معارك
عنيفه مع ميليشيا الحوثي والقوات
للرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما هي القيمه الميدانيه للتطورات
العسكريه الاخيره في تعز وما الظروف التي
جاءت في
سياقها وما هي فرص نجاح هذه التطورات في
فك الحصار الخانق الذي تتعرض له المدينه
منذ عده
اشهر
اذا على محاور عديده في الجبهتين الغربيه
والجنوبيه لمدينه تعز تواصل المقاومه
الشعبيه وقوات الجيش الوطني تقدمها منذ
يوم الخميس في مواقع كانت تسيطر عليها
ميليشيا الحوثيين والقوات المواليه للرئيس
اليمني المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح تقدم
بسطت معه المقاومه وقوات الجيش الوطني
سيطرتها على مناطق مثل مطار تعز القديم
واللواء 35 مدرع غربي المدينه اضافه الى
جبل ورقه في شقها الجنوبي تقرير فاطمه
تريكي الله اكبر ولله الحمد ليس كسبا
عاديا على ارض معركه ولا تقدما في جبهات
على سهول وسفوح خاويه هنا مشاعر نصر وفرح
بطعم الحياه ففي كل خطوه تتقدم فيها هذه
القوات داخل تعز تكسر حلقه من حصار الموت
والتجويع المفروض على ثالث اكبر مدن اليمن
منذ عشره اشهر المحاصرون مئات الاف البشر
بلا غذاء ولا دواء ولا وقود انهم يمنيون
والمحاصر ايضا يمنيون اواصر لم تشفع
للمدينه الموصوفه تاريخيا باعتدال ومناخها
الثقافي الجامع من ان تكون ضحيه تطلعات
ميليشيا مسلحه تمثل اقليه شعبيه تلاقت مع
ه سلطه رئيس مخلوع لا يظهر من اثر عهده
الطويل في حاضر اليمن غير العذاب والفقر
وقرر الاستيلاء على بلد يكبرهم بكثير منذ
الاربعاء بدات المعارك والتقدم على جبهه
تعز ليس فقط لفك الحصار بل والعبور منها
لمناطق اخرى وتطبيق ما يعرف بالتحام
الجبهات بحسب محافظ المدينه يوم الجمعه
تقدمت قوات المقاومه وقوات الحكومه فسيطرت
تواليا على مطار المدينه القديم ثم على
اللواء 35 مدرع الهجوم على التلال التي
يطوق منها مسلح الحوثي وصالح نصف مليون
انسان كان الهدف الاول خصر تله الاريال
وتله الارانب ومنطقه بير باشا والتقدم جار
باتجاه جامعه تعز كما سيطرت قوات المقاومه
على جبل ورقه جنوبا التطور الحالي هو
الاكبر على هذه الجبهه التي ظلت ماساه
اهلها تتفاقم
وسط جدل كبير رافق عدم حسم معركتها واسباب
ذلك واهمها ضعف تسليح قوات المقاومه
والجيش فضلا عن استماته الحوثيين ومن معهم
للاحتفاظ بمواقعهم لما لها من وقع معنوي
واهميه جغرافيه عسكريه فهل تتجه الامور
الان في اتجاه اكثر حسما على الارض من تعز
الى باقي اليمن في الشرق والغرب والشمال
بعد الجنوب انها الارض التي اخذ الحوثيون
وحليفهم في ايام غفله او خطا قاتل ويشدون
عليها الان بالنواجذ ورقه وحيده واخيره
وفي انتظار خلاصهم المكلف يبذل اليمنيون
من ارواحهم واموالهم اما الامال
فمعلوم قديم اظهر قبل خمس سنوات ثم طعن
حلم بدوله حديثه
يستحقونها موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع فنا من
عمان سمير الحاج مستشار رئيس الاركان
والناطق باسم الجيش اليمني من تعز ضياء
الحق ادريس الاهدل مقرر مجلس تنسيق
المقاومه الشعبيه في تعز ومن لندن محمد
جميح الكاتب والباحث السياسي اليمني وابدا
بضيفي من تعز ومعه نعرف
اخر المستجدات خاصه فيما يتعلق بالجبهه
الجنوبيه الغربيه لهذه المدينه مدينه
تعز
اهلا وسهلا اخي الكريم ونشكر لكم اهتمامكم
وتغطيت
لحدث التقدمات التي ان شاء الله عز وجل ان
يمن بها علينا فله الحمد اولا واخيرا ثم
ايضا الفضل لرجال المقاومه الابطال حقيقه
الواقع كما ورد في تقريركم الاخباري ان
هنالك تقدمات حقيقيه مؤثره تاثيرا كبيرا
على ميدان المعركه في الجبهه الغربيه
وكذلك في الجبهه الجنوبيه المقا اليوم
تستطيع نستطيع ان ان نقول انها خطت خطوات
كبيره وايجابيه في تحقيق هدفها المنشود في
فك الحصار عن مدينه تعز من خط تمويلي وخط
تمويلي واسع وهو
خط المدينه الحجريه هذا الخط الذي يربطه
تعز بعدن ايضا وبالتالي فاننا نقول ان ما
حدث اليوم وفي الايام الماضيه الثلاث
الايام الماضيه هو على واقع الارض تقدما
عسكريا كبيرا وان كبير لا
سيماي كامله ما نوع السيطره هل هي كامله
على الجهات الجنوبيه والغربيه ام
ماذا نعم تكاد تكون اليوم الجبهه الجنوبيه
امنت تامينا كاملا
واصبحت
بالسيطره اليوم على بقايا المناطق في
الاقروض والمطال وجبل ورقه الجبهه
الجنوبيه مؤمنه وفي للمدينه و في سيطره
المقاومه سيطره تامه عليها ومؤمنه كذلك
كذلك المواقع الغربيه في الجبهات الغربيه
التي اليوم سيطرت عليها المقاومه في هذا
اليوم ويوم الامس والاول من امس ايضا
مواقع هامه
واستراتيجيه في تامين هذا الخط نحن اليوم
نكاد ان نقول ان هذا الخط اصبح خطا امنا
وان بقي فيه فقط مساله الالتحام النهائي
بجبهه ال اهميه و سؤالي موجه ضيفي من عمان
سمير
الحاج ما قيمه ما تحقق فيما يتعلق بالهدف
الاول وهو رفع الحصار على هذه المدينه
المحاصره منذ
شهور شكرا لك اخي الكريم ومشاهدي الكرام
وضيفك ضيفك الكريمين في حقيقه
الامر الانتصار اليوم في تعز يعد تحولا
كبيرا جدا نحن امام كسر ربما يعني ل الثقل
الحوثي في اللواء 35 مدرع والجبهه الغربيه
اليوم تحررت هذه المنطقه طبعا بفضل ابناء
الجيش الوطني والمقاومه الشعبيه الذين
اليوم ادوا اداء اليوم امس وقبل امس اداء
رائعا جدا وايضا تكمن اهميه هذا المحور في
ان بانه سيكون البوابه الرئيسيه لفك
الحصار على المدينه فكما تعلمون ان المدخل
الغربي هو الواصل الرئيسي مع منطقه المخا
والبحر ومع منطقه الحديده ايضا والباب
المندب كل هذه المناطق تصب في هذا المدخل
فالمدن وبي نستطيع ان نقول انه تحرر اليوم
تماما وايضا لدينا الان المدخل
الغربي تبقى بعض النقاط بعد ما بعد اللواء
35 سيتم تجاوزها باذن الله تعالى وسيكون
لها اثر كبير في فك الحصار على المدينه ا
ضيفي من لندن الدكتور محمد جميع فيما
يتعلق برايك ما الذي توفر حتى تحقق هذا
الانجاز فيما يتعلق بالجهات الجنوبيه
والغربيه ماذا عن السياقات التي دفعت وادت
الى هذه النتيجه حتى
الان انا اعتقد انه يمكن النظر الى سياقات
في من ناحيتين الناحيه الاولى ال ناحيه
الاعداد والتجهيز خلال الشهور الماضيه كان
اليمني وفي تعز تحديدا ينتظرون بفارغ
الصبر اللحظه التي حانت قبل ثلاث ايام
والتي ما زالت مستمره الى اليوم لكن كان
ذلك يتطلب اعدادا جيدا تجهيزا تدريبا نقلا
لمعدات
من قوات التحالف والجيش الوطني الى
المقاومه والى الجيش ايضا الوطني في تعز
معسكرات تدريب كانت خلال الايام وخلال
الشهور بالاحرى الماضيه كانت قائمه على
قدم وساق لتدريب عناصر مدربه هي التي بعد
عون الله طبعا انجزت ما تحقق خلال الايام
الماضيه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى ان
الانهيارات التي مني بها الحوثيون في
صنعاء وفي الجوف وفي مارب اثرت في تصوري
على معنويات مقاتليهم في تعز الذين
يقاتلون بعيدا عن
مركز السلطه في صنعاء
والذين ربما بداوا يتسائلون على ماذا ن
قاتل ونحن اليوم تهدد صنعاء في المديريه
الاولى من مديرياتها في نهم وقوات الجيش
الوطني والمقاومه موجوده هناك وبالتالي في
تصوري ايضا لا يمكن اغفال حقيقه ان
الطيران التحالف كان له دور كبير ايضا في
اعطاء التغطيه الجويه اللازمه لكن
بالمحصول النهائيه اعتقد ان حاله الياس
التي وصل اليها المقاتلون الحوثيون
والميليشيات التابعه لصالح هي التي كانت
جزءا مهما وراء ما حصل من انهيارات اليوم
في تعز وكالات الانباء اوردت عن عشرات
الاطقم العسكريه التي بدات تنقل المقاتلين
هروبا من تعز باتجاه الحديده على الساحل
الغربي الى الشمال الغربي من مدينه تعز
اذا الحاله المعنويه للمقاتلين في تعز
الحوثيين لم تعد كما كانت من قبل
الانهيارات التي كانت في منا وهذا وهذا ما
يدفعني الى سؤال ضيفي من تعز ضياء الحق
فيما يتعلق بهذه مره سبق وان تقدمت
المقاومه في بعض المحاور او النقاط ثم
تراجعت وعاد الحوثيون والموالون الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح واستعادوا هذه
الاماكن في مرات سابقه ماذا عن هذه المره
ما الذي يجعل هذا التقدم
ثابتا اقول ليس ليس ما قلته دقيقه 100%
التقدمات السابقه ايضا ظلت محصنه ومنيع
على الحوثيين ثناء بعض التباب في خطوط
التماس التي هي محميه بتبب اخرى او
بمرتفعات محصنه ومحافظه عليها لكن اليوم
المساحه الكبيره التي سيطرت عليها
المقاومه الشعبيه والجيش الوطني تجعل
الصعوبه كبيره جدا في التفكير في المحاوله
لاستعادتها لانها اصبحت مؤمنه
واصبحت ظهر الحوثيين منكشف اليوم على غير
ذ قبل كان الحوثيون في انسقه قريبه من
الانسه التي تحررت سابقا ويمتلكون مراكز
ربما جغرافيا لها سيطره وهيمنه على بعض ما
كنا قد تحررنا ربما كان هذا عاملا من
عوامل عدم القدره على البقاء في خطوط
محدوده من خطوط التماس لكن اليوم الانفراج
الكبير الذي سيطرت من خلاله المقاومه على
مراكز مراكز السيطره ومواقع مرتفعه واتبا
المتعدده تحمي بعضها بعضا و وتمثل انسجه
وتحصينات حقيقيه جغرافيه طبيعيه اولا ثم
معنويه المقاتلين في مساله الحمايه لا شك
انها في تنامي وتصاعد اضافه الى خبراتنا
القتاليه والتي اشار اليها الاستاذ في
مساله التدريب الذي نالته المقاومه
الشعبيه والخبره المتراكمه التي تكتسبها
المقاومه يوما بعد يوم كل هذه عوامل
تجعلنا نقول انه باذن الله تعالى لن
يستطيع الحوثي ان ان يستعيد شيئا مما قد
تحرر اليوم بل سيند حر عما لازال باقيا
فيه وسيتم التحرير ان شاء الله تعالى سيد
سمير الحاج اليوم في تصريح للجزيره من قبل
محافظ تعز اصبح الكلام الان عن مناطق خارج
تعز والتحرك باتجاهها باتجاه اب باتجاه
الحديده ومناطق اخرى ما الذي يدعم هذا
التوجه بالنظر الى ما يجري من معطيات حتى
الان في
تعز
على ايه حال بالنسبه
للتحرك خارج تعز اعتقد ان ابناء تعز اولا
لن يكتفوا فقط
بربما يعني تحرير وسط المدينه واطرافها
وانما لا بد ان يقوموا بتحرير اولا كامل
المحافظه والمحافظه محافظه تعز طبعا
امتداد لمحافظه لاحق لمحافظه اب
يضا طريق الحد ديده الرئيسيه يمر من هذه
المحافظه ومن ثم اعتقد ان المعطيات على
الارض تقول بانه اذا تم التحرير الكامل
لمحافظه تعز فان الجبهات الاخرى اعتقد
انها لن تقاوم كثيرا وستسقط سريعا سواء في
الحديده او في اب او في ذمار او في اي
منطقه اخرى على كل فاصل قصير نناقش بعده
امكانيه البناء على هذه التطورات
الميدانيه لتخليص المدينه من الحصار
المفروض عليها منذ عده اشهر ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش فرص نجاح محاولات فك الحصار عن تعز
في ضوء التطورات الميدانيه الاخيره في
المدينه واجدد التحيه لضيوف هذه الحلقه
دكتور محمد فيما يتعلق بالهدف من هذه
العمليه وهو فك الحصار على على هذه
المدينه المحاصره منذ عده اشهر بالنظر الى
هذه التطورات الى اي مدى هذا الهدف اصبح
قريب اكثر من اي وقت مضى
برايك اعتقد انه قريب الطبع اكثر من اي
وقت مضى لان ما حصل خلال الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه لم يكن كما حصل في وقت مضى كان
تطورا نوعيا و وملموسا يعني ليس من قبيل
التطورات الاعلاميه وانما الحقائق موجوده
على الارض ا
ال هذا النصر الذي حصل اليوم للمقاومه
سيسهم في تكريس عدد من الحقائق منها ان صف
الانقلابيين بدا بالتفكك وهذا ربما كان
عاملا من العوامل التي ادت الى ما حصل
خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه ثانيا ان
عاملا اخر وهو عامل توحد المقاومه بعد
شعورها بالنصر
والتحامها بالجيش الوطني سيكون ايضا له
دورا او سيكون له دور كبير خلال الايام
القادمه اذا لدينا عوامل تضعضع الطرف
الانقلابي بدخول خلافات وتخويف اطرافه
المختلفه اليوم الحرس الجمهوري هناك انباء
تقول بانه هناك مواجهات بين الحوثيين
والحرس الجمهوري في بعض المناطق خارج تعز
بعد ان اتهمهم الحرس الجمهوري بانهم تركوا
الجبهه الغربيه وفروا من من هذه الجبهه و
طبعا ناهيك عن الخلافات السياسيه بين
الطرفين الحوثيين وعلي عبد الله صالح التي
لابد انها سيكون لها اثر على الواقع
الميداني بينما المقاومه كل يوم يشتد
عودها وتلتحم مع فصائلها المختلفه تلتحم
مع الجيش الوطني ا يزيد تنسيقها وتزيد
خبرتها القتاليه هذا بلا شك سيصب في
الاخير في المحصله نهائيه لصالح رفع
الحصار عن تعز اليوم الجهه الجنوبيه عندما
تتحرر هذا يعني انفتاح ال المدينه على
الجنوب بمعنى ان الخط يمكن ان يؤمن اي بين
بين تعز والجنوب ما عدا بعض الجيوب
الموجوده في ريف تعز والتي يمكن اذا ما
استمر المد على ما هو عليه خلال الايام
الثلاثه الاخيره فانه يمكن التعامل مع هذه
الجوب الموجوده في ريف تعز ويجب استغلال
الروح المعنويه المنهاره للمقاتلين من
قوات الانقلاب ومواصله هذه الروح المعنويه
العاليه لدى قوات المقاومه والجيش الوطني
من اجل ولو فتح نافذه لا ينبغي ان ان ان
نبالغ في في في في ما حصل هناك لا يزال
الحصار مضروبا على المدينه وانما اتوقع
خلال الايام القادمه ان تنفتح فتحه كبيره
جدا في هذا الحصار من الجهتين الغربيه
والجنوبيه وهذا ما سيسرع بانف كاك حلقات
هذا الحصار المفروض على المدينه منذ فتره
طويله طيب ما اشر قبل قليل دكتور محمد
فيما يتعلق بهذه العلاقه بين المقاومه
الشعبيه وبين الجيش الشعبي وهنا اسال ضيفي
من تعز سيد ضياء الحق عن ما ماذا عن هذه
العلاقه التي يقرا من خلالها هذا التطور
الحاصل في اداء المقاومه والجيش الوطني في
اليمن في ما يجري على
الارض احب ان اؤكد هنا ان العلاقه بيننا
وبين الجيش الوطني ليست وليده لحظه متاخره
من المقاومه نحن منذ البدايه والمقاومه
فيها من افراد الجيش الوطني
الذين يعني رفضوا الانصياع لاوامر
الانقلابيين منذ الوهله الاولى والمقاومه
مكونه من افراد من الجيش الوطني وافراد من
المقاومه الشعبيه المدنيين الذين التحموا
معا ابتداء لكن ما حدث اخيرا ربما هو انها
بدات تشكيلات الجيش الوطني تعود الى
واقعها التكويني والهرمي الذي ربما اعطاها
صوره جديده لا سما ما حدث من تدريب عدد
غير قليل تقريبا 1000 متدرب من الجيش
الوطني في معسكر العند هؤلاء افوا اضافوا
اضافه جديده ربما اما حقيقه الامر في
الجيش الوطني والمقاومه الشعبيه في تعز
بافراد الجيش ملتحمه والمجلس العسكري
ومجلس تنسيق المقاومه كله لا يتجزا منذ
البدايه لكن اقول ان الالتحام على ميدان
الجبهه اليوم ربما كان هو الاضاء الجديده
اليوم في الجبهات الغربيه على سبيل المثال
قتلت فصائل كل الجبهات سواء في الجبهه
الشرقيه او
الجبهه الشماليه او الجبهه الجنوبيه
وبالتالي ربما هذا هو الالتحام الذي استجد
وجد اما حقيقه العلاقه فالجيش الوطني في
تعز والوطنيون من ابناء الجيش في تعز
ملتحمين بالمقاومه ربما بغير مسمى الجيش
منذ ولتها الاولى الخبرات متبادله
والشراكه فعليه وعمليه الجديد ربما بدات
تتشكل الويه الجيش الوطني بشكل اخر في
المرحله بشكل جدي وحقيقي في المرحله
الاخيره هذا هو ربما المستجد الذي اضفى
امرا جديد اضافه الى الخبرات المكتسبه في
فتره التدريب والتاهيل الاخيره سيد سمير
الحاج في الشهور الماضيه اكثر من مره قيل
عن الاستعداد وعن الحسم هذه المره في فك
الحصار عن مدينه تعز وتخليص الناس من
معاناتهم الانسانيه هل لكم ان توجهوا كلمه
الان واكيد يشاهدنا الكثير من اهالي تعز
فيما يتعلق ب رفع هذه المعاناه وتحسين
واقعهم الانساني وما يجي لهم يوما بعد يوم
على ايه حال اذا كان هناك من قول ف نحن
نوجه النداء اولا
ل ابناء القوات المسلحه بشكل عام الذي
لازالوا يعني يعني يعملون في صف الحوثي
وصالح والذين ربما هم مغلوبون على امرهم
نوجه لهم نداء اولا ان يتركوا السلاح وان
ينحازوا الى الشعب والوطن هذا اولا
بالنسبه لابناء تعز فاولا نهنئهم بهذا
النصر الكبير
ونتمنى عليهم ان يكونوا كما
عهدناهم وس يعني دائما يمثلون الوطن كل
الوطن لان تعز هي حاضره وخاصه الوطن بشكل
عام فينبغي ان الان بعد هذا النصر ان تكون
نموذج باذن الله تعالى ل الدوله المدنيه
الحديثه التي ينشرها اليمنيون بشكل عام
انا اتوقع ذلك و
ويعني اتوجه ايضا بالنداء للاخوه في في
الجيش الوطني الاستمرار
في الحيطه والحذر والانتباه والعمل بشكل
منظم ابقى معك سيد سمير ابقى معك ايضا هذا
اليوم وفقط في ربما في اللحظات السابقه
محافظ تعز وجه نداء الى ضروره دعم
المقاومه والجيش بالذخيره وقال بان هناك
نقص فيما يتعلق بهذه الذخيره ماذا عن
خططكم للامداد مادام ان النتائج بهذا
الشكل
علىيه حال بخصوص الامداد فعلا نحن نعمل
كمنظومه الحقيقه نحن دوله من دول التحالف
والاخوه في التحالف يدركون جيدا ان معركه
بهذا الحجم وبهذه السعه تحتاج الى مقدار
اكبر من الذخائر ومن العتاد والسلاح لغرض
استمرار ديمومه النصر وتثبيت المواقع
المحرره اعتقد ان اخواننا في التحالف
يضعون هذا نص بعينهم
وان الامر يتعلق ربما بالوقت فقط ولا بد
ان تصل مثل هذه الدعم قريبا جدا دكتور
محمد اعيد طرح سؤال معك بصيغه مختلفه ما
يتعلق بمدى جديه هذه المره عند الحديث على
انه سيحسم الامر في تعز ويفك الحصار عن
هذه المدينه الى اي مدى هذه المره فعلا
هناك نيه واجراءات حقيقيه لفك الحصار عن
هذه المدينه ايا كانت
الحسابات انا اعتقد ان النيه موجوده لفك
الحصار عن المدينه لكن كانت الوسائل مغيبه
فيما مضى لعده عوامل من ضمنها ايضا ان
الفصائل المقاومه لم تكن كما هي عليه الان
من التوحد كان هناك نوع من عدم التنسيق
بين فصائل المقاومه في السابق اليوم هذا
التنسيق موجود كان هناك نوع من عدم
التنسيق بين فصائل المقاومه والجيش الوطني
بشكل كبير ولكنه اليوم موجود بشكل اكبر
كان ايضا هناك نوع من
ال يعني من من عدم وجود دعم كاف للمقاومه
والجيش الوطني نتيجه للظروف الجغرافيه في
تعز نتيجه لبعض العوامل السياسيه التي
كانت تمنع وصول بعض الامدادات من الجنوب
الى مدينه تعز اليوم في تصوري ان كثيرا من
هذه العوامل ذابت ثم ان الحاله السياسيه
والميدانيه للانقلابيين في البلاد تمر
بحاله انهيار اجبرت فريقا من الانقلابيين
وهم الحوثي
الى توقيع نوع من الهدنه او اتفاق على نوع
من الهدنه الميدانيه فيما يخص الشريط
الحدودي من جهه محافظه صعده وهذا مؤشر على
ان هؤلاء بدا جانبهم يتضعضع ولذلك شنت
عليهم وسائل المؤتمر الشعبي العام
الاعلاميه في الفيسبوك وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي هجوما كبيرا بانهم قد وجهوا
طعنه للرئيس السابق وطعنه لحلفائه في
المؤتمر الشعبي العام والحرس الجمهوري هذه
العوامل اذا ما استمر تساوقها بهذه
الوتيره فانها ستعجل بعمليه ضعضع وارتخاء
قبضه الحوثيين والانقلابين على دكتور محمد
اعقد كلمه ضعه لاس ضيفي من تعز ضياء الحق
كيف يمكن استغلال هذه الضع في الحصار
المطبق على تعز في ايصال مساعدات انسانيه
سريعه لاهالي
تعز
سيد ضيا
تسمعني سيد ضيا تسمعني نعم نعم السؤال كان
مواجه لك السؤال كان مواجه لكريم نعم
سالتك عن كيف يمكن استغلال الوضع الحالي
اقول ان تفضل
تفضل لا شك ان الوضع الذي يوشك ان يكتمل
الليله باذن الله تعالى او في اليوم
القادم باذ تعالى ان تاخر وهو فتح
خط خط سير اسفلتي يربطه مدينه تعز بمحافظه
بالمحافظات الجنوبيه بعدن ولحق وبالتالي
سيكون وصول المواد الغذائيه والاغاثه
الانسانيه بصوره سلسه وسهله وهذا كله
سيحقق لا شك ولا ريب مساله فك الصار اليوم
على سبيل المثال بدا بدات بواج فك الحصار
على سبيل
المثال عندما توسع ضيا الحق ادريس الاهدل
شكرا جزيلا لك مقرر مجلس تنسيق المقاومه
الشعبيه في تعس كما اشكر ضيفي من عمان
سمير الحاج مستشار رئيس الاركان والناطق
باسم الجيش اليمني وكذلك ضيفي من لندن
محمد جميح الكاتب والباحث السياسي
اليمني الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه